sherry and good morning to you there is  one crash on the i-15  around the 215 southern beltway but  generally speaking here  just after five o'clock on your friday  morning the freeway is in pretty good  shape let's take you down here to the  northbound side of the i-15  north of the 215 you'll be able to see a  legion stadium off here in the distance  so there's emergency equipment on the  left shoulder they're blocking the left  lane  also some emergency equipment on the  right shoulder traffic is rolling on  through somebody else just showing up  here so  some immediate slowing in the vicinity  but not enough traffic to really be  blocked up just watch out northbound on  the i-15  around the 215 southern beltway we'll  continue to watch all the freeways for  you  all morning long john